all right it's time for the mailbag you
can email info at davidpakman.com if you
have something to say it might be
featured on the show keep it polite keep
it substantive keep it productive
yeah only like five percent of people do
but
we have a lot of those five percent to
be featured today uh let's jump uh jump
right into some of these max wrote in
and max very very upset
says will you admit you were wrong about
russia russia russia
david you incredulously made fun of
trump when he was talking about russia
russia russia you even pretended or
purposely were ignorant and said you
don't even know what he's talking about
will you ever admit you were wrong and
trump was right michael sussman is on
trial for exactly what trump was talking
about it turns out the whole russiagate
scandal was generated by the hillary
clinton campaign personally approved
hillary clinton then surreptitiously fed
to the fbi will you ever acknowledge
that you that or will you continue to
pretend like this didn't happen well in
fact uh i can't think of anything in
particular that i was wrong about when
it comes to russia russia russia michael
sussman was acquitted by a jury
now people are saying oh the jury wasn't
a good jury well that's the process we
have
um and i mean listen i never said trump
was going to be caught on video plotting
stuff with putin we were nuanced and
specific
in terms of uh what what we thought went
on and uh so i'll admit i i have no
problem admitting i was wrong about
things when i'm wrong about them max
also writing also when will you admit
that the wuhan lab story is not only
real but leftists and big tech censored
us for years for talking about it and
you have no problem with that same with
the hunter biden laptop from hell's
story yep i covered both stories
um we follow evidence and uh that's it
max i'm sorry you're sort of living in a
fantasy world okay jumping jack flash
wrote in and said i watched your
rebroadcast of trump's wyoming speech i
quickly learned from your narrative
interruptions during trump's speech that
you're quite a moronic a-hole good job
perhaps your mother should have aborted
you
what a beautiful message of peace and
love and productivity you know when i
get a message like this i really think
to myself
i should reconsider my opinions and
political views because this is so
it's just so respectfully written and it
just really makes you think
introspectively could i be wrong and so
i am going to revisit all of my
political views thanks to this email
isn't that beautiful okay richard rhoden
richard says that um he joined trump's
platform truth social which trump calls
truth central truth essential yeah uh
richard says so david i was jaw dropped
for the first three minutes after
joining troth central after that i
realized it's literally 90 trolls it's a
turd spiraling the drain yeah there's a
lot of bot like
and sort of troll-like activity on there
and
i i joined sort of like as an experiment
you know i'm not really expecting any
kind of
uh major dialogue or anything like that
there but
i encourage others just to check it out
and the replies to the things i post are
extremely nuts very very nuts
um it could survive i mean listen they
quite literally cloned twitter the
website is just a copy of twitter and so
to the extent that twitter is successful
at least truth set truth social now i'm
saying it truth central at least truth
social is starting with like a a a
layout a user experience that kind of
makes sense but i don't know if you told
me a year from now truth social will be
huge i'd be like yeah maybe if you told
me a year from now truth social will be
shut down i'd say yeah that that's
plausible too justin wrote in about gun
control
um justin from dallas or jr from dallas
as he goes by says david relatively new
listener would love to hear your
thoughts on the debate technique that
gun rights folks use when debating gun
control of assault weapons they tend to
start lecturing the gun the control
advocate on the technicalities of the
guns to show their supposedly informed
knowledge it's ridiculous how would you
respond well
yes it's very popular when we start
saying hey look like assault style
rifles keep being used in mass shootings
there's a couple approaches they'll take
one is they'll say
most gun deaths are from handguns it's
like yes that's true that's a different
problem there's really there's there's
really three problems actually when it
comes to gun violence
or organ deaths i should better say it's
death by suicide with a gun
what we might call one-off
gun homicides which includes one or two
victims remember it's only a mass
shooting when it goes beyond that uh
either to three or four victims
depending on which statistics you look
at so then you've got your sort of like
handgun typically handgun based
incidents which are one or two victims
and then you've got your mass shooting
so one technique is they'll say
more people die from handguns what are
you going to ban hand guns it's like
well no we're proposing different things
when it comes to the assault rifles
semi-automatics large capacity magazines
etc we want age limits we want you know
all these different things separately
let's talk about the handgun piece as
well so one important thing is to say
we have many issues with firearms and we
have different solutions for each of
them then they'll get into what is an
assault style rifle anyway i can change
the appearance of this firearm and make
it not an assault rifle but it's still
sort of the same firearm or
i can show you a firearm that looks
different but still technically is an
assault rifle
what we have to do is just kind of zoom
out and go okay but hold on a second
the same type of firearm continues to be
used in mass shootings frequently
whether i can identify every example of
it doesn't really matter we can have
informed opinions about military
conflicts without knowing every last
detail about military strategy or tanks
or whatever the case may be and it's
really sort of a red herring to avoid
talking about the most important thing
so you've got you've got to take control
back of the situation i think is the
point i'm trying to make
aj wrote in about the night before the
january 6th insurrection and aj said
david sir
marjorie taylor green has the same shoes
as the person of interest in the dc pipe
bombing suspect the night before the
january sixth insurrection what do you
think david is it just a coincidence
dozens of people have written to me
about this and they've said
we have no suspect for the pipe bombing
yet
the gate of the individual sort of seems
like it could be marjorie taylor green
it seems like it could be a woman rather
than a man these are the i don't know if
that's true people people write to me
and then most recently
the shoes worn in the surveillance video
by the
pipe bomber
are shoes that marjorie taylor green
also owns listen everybody's right about
all those things
big picture
i agree with all those things it sort of
looks like it could be marjorie taylor
green's gate
it is these are the shoes that marjorie
taylor green has been seen wearing uh we
don't have a it's all true it's
completely circumstantial it's
completely speculative it is truly
starting to get strange that there's
still no suspect for the dc pipe bombing
attempt from january 5th into january
6th i don't know what to think about it
could it be marjorie taylor green
at this point i can't rule it out but it
is very speculative
and it should be investigated for sure
stephanie wrote in and says
thanks for the membership sale david sir
because of your irresponsibly cheap
memorial day sale i have finally been
able to buy a membership to the david
pakman show i've been wanting to for a
while but couldn't quite find the funds
sometimes sales are not as amazing as
they are made out to be but this really
was a great discount and it made my
membership possible super excited to be
on board and to be putting my money
where my mind is keep it up your work is
so needed
thank you stephanie you know i spoke on
a live stream last week
i was genuinely bummed out i got about
two dozen emails
when my paternity leave started
saying things like david i just signed
up and now you're on paternity leave
cancel my membership
or
i didn't know i was going to be paying
for repeats or
you think you can just
abandon your audience and keep my
youtube subscription you're out of your
mind
and i was so bummed out because it's
like guys aren't we progressive aren't
we in favor of paid paternity leave that
doesn't mean you have to fund my
paternity leave but like i am
self-employed at the end of the day
right where where do you think the money
comes from and in particular from the
people that don't even pay
the show is free like there's a little
bit of entitlement in saying how dare i
take time off from something you get
literally for free you don't pay
anything for the show so i love that
a bunch of people
like stephanie and others later got in
touch and said david
uh
i i apologize on behalf of those people
those are not real progressives real
progressives would understand what's
going on here and the importance of
paternity leave
um but it was it was a little bit of a
of a bum out moment like and also i i
said this on my recent live stream too
this is kind of why the right wins
because they you know the example i gave
was you've got all these right wingers
who fund charlie kirk do you think
they're watching his show or counting
his days off or whatever no they just go
this guy is saying the things the types
of things that we want said so we're
just gonna fund it and that's it
and uh this is one of the real
differences between left and right and
we've experienced it on the show many
many times before the right gets you've
got to just fund this stuff and let it
exist because you think it should exist
and uh you know counting days off or
talking about repeats it's a little bit
concerning all right there's there's my
rant i'm off the soapbox tom wrote in
about lgbt nomenclature and tom says
this is a semantics correction
suggestion
i think there is this is tom writing i
think there's a push to revert to the
initial lgbt
instead of lgbtq or lgbtq plus to stop
the disgruntled size of people thinking
oh lgbtq abcd it's just too much people
that i know personally that are active
in the community always say lgbt for
this reason
i have never changed to be perfectly
frank
um i i've been saying lgbt from the
start i don't think i ever used lgbt
plus
or lgbtq
uh i have no um desire to exclude anyone
from any group with which they identify
um but i i am it's interesting it hasn't
even occurred to me to change the word i
use because i know that my audience
knows exactly the group i'm talking
about
whether or not i say lgbt or lgbtq for
queer people that ident which is i guess
you know a more general term
my my audience knows my views on this my
audience knows my my inclusivity on this
issue um so i've just never felt the
need and quite frankly nobody's ever
really corrected me that i'm aware of i
mean okay i don't look at youtube
comments but i i think people sort of
get the point
of uh
of of
my the language i use but yes i have
noticed i am just i am seeing a lot of
lgbt appearing again
rather than the longer ones listen we're
fighting for people's rights let's get
people rights that's what i care about
ryan says masks are traumatizing but
robocop guards are just fine yeah this
is a really good commentary on the uh
armed teachers thing ryan says just
wanted to point out that forcing kids
to wear masks would cause irreparable
damage to children's psyche sure it
would save a few lives but we simply
can't risk our kids well-being oh but
let's go ahead and arm the teachers hire
an army of armed guards maybe even build
a few robocops at the entrance of the
schools they'll be fine with that right
yeah the and the point is one i've
tweeted about previously
we couldn't do masks in schools because
it would just be too traumatizing to the
children
but it's fine to arm teachers send kids
to school
uh with bulletproof backpacks and
ballistic shield blankets and all of
these things that's fine but the masks
were just too much it's crazy it's crazy
and lastly today from julie julie says
david sir i'm embarrassed and almost
feel sorry for the triggered
projectionist trumpets that think
they're trolling you most of us see
through their br blatant failed attempts
to own the libs and might find it
amusing if it weren't so sad you're
obviously doing something right keep up
the tremendous work thank you julie
julie adds a ps ps please don't shave
your head when you hit the two million
subscriber mark on youtube well let's
see if we can get me past the 1.5
million subscriber mark first and then
we'll figure out listen if we got to 2
million it would be such a major
milestone i would consider shaving my
head i i don't know that anybody would
care about it but i would consider doing
it info davidpakman.com send me your
thoughts